To talk about electric potential energy, let's imagine a universe
that only has two charges in it and let's say they're both positive.
And the separation between these charges we'll call r.
And what I want to know is when do you think electric potential energy
which I'm using a big U with the subscript E to indicate--when do you think that's highest?
Do you think it's highest when r is big? when it's small? Or maybe it doesn't matter what r is.
Now when you're thinking about this question,
I want you to think okay there's two positive charges. Are they going to attract or repel?
Given whatever that tendency is, if I move them closer
well is there going to be more energy stored in them or less?
Are they going to have more capacity to do work or less?